[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE MCDONALD: My
name is Mike McDonald.
And I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud Platform.
I've worked on Firebase for
about 5, 5 and 1/2 years,
so I've been building
mobile apps for a long time.
And today, we're going
to go through a couple
of the kind of best
practices that I've
seen that build secure apps.
And kind of conversely, I've
seen a lot of insecure apps,
right?
I've seen websites that
I can go to and download
an entire database, just
because they didn't follow
a couple of really simple tips.
So first of all, just to
level set, how many people
have used Firebase, or how
many have heard of Firebase,
to start with?
Great.
Awesome.
How many people have built an
app and shipped it on Firebase?
OK, about half the room.
Awesome.
So if anyone needs to, feel
free to run out of the room
and just start screaming
if you see something
that you're doing wrong.
And then we can hopefully
fix that really quickly.
Otherwise, for the rest
of you, hopefully, it's
not too repetitive.
But we're going to go
into a lot of really
in-depth examples of how to
build secure apps on Firebase.
So hopefully this
isn't too old hat.
But if you wanted to build
a traditional mobile or web
application, you'd build
something like this.
So your mobile app or your
browser talks to a web server.
And that web server is
running Python and Django.
Or maybe it's running Ruby
on Rails, things like that.
And within that
server, not only are
you doing the business logic
of what your application does,
but there are a lot
of ambient concerns
that you have to deal with.
You have to
authenticate your users.
You have to make sure
they're authorized to do
what they're allowed to do.
Maybe you have to
validate schema
because you're writing to a
database or some other API.
And then you have to deal
with a bunch of other things
that are just running and
managing infrastructure.
So doing OS or language
runtime updates.
Unless you're using
some serverless compute,
maybe you're not doing that.
But the point is there
is a lot of stuff
going on that is not
directly related to what
your application is doing.
And so that's the whole
premise of Firebase, right?
Firebase is eliminate
that middle tier server,
and let your applications
talk directly
to managed infrastructure.
So let them talk
directly to a database,
or let them upload
a file directly
to a Cloud Storage bucket.
And that obviously presents
a lot of issues, right?
Like untrusted clients
on the internet.
The internet is a
very scary place
if you haven't already
spent a lot of time there.
Right?
If you just look at web
server logs of a web server
that you run, say,
on a GCE instance,
you see IP addresses coming
from all over the world, right?
People are doing malicious
things on the internet.
You want to put yourself
kind of ahead of the rest
of the internet by doing a
couple of really little things
to really make yourself secure.
So we're going to go
through those tips.
By building an
application, right?
So we're all at a conference.
I did not travel very far.
I live in the Bay Area.
But I'm sure many
of you are here.
And you have to
expense things, right?
So I don't know how
tedious of a process
it is at your companies,
but some companies, you
have to fax receipts in.
It's terrible.
We want to build a better
expense reporting experience,
right?
So I want to take a photo
and have that photo somehow
magically become
a number, right?
We can use fancy
Machine Learning things.
I've heard a lot about that.
And we'll actually use Firebase
to build this experience.
I think we can do it
really, really quickly.
So I have myself.
And the first thing that I
need to do when I'm building
an application-- and we're
talking kind of any normal
application--
I need to authenticate myself.
I need to say, hi, I'm
Mike, and I need some way
of actually proving that.
So I can get information
about myself.
And then I need to
upload that photo.
And so we're living
in a Firebase world.
I can use Cloud
storage for Firebase,
and suck that photo
right up off my device,
and drop it in a
Cloud Storage bucket.
And then we can use the
magic of Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions are kind
of event driven compute off
of various services.
So whenever an object is
dropped in my storage bucket,
I can trigger a function.
And then I'm not a
super savvy developer.
I'm just going to call
the Cloud Vision API.
I'm not going to write my
own OCR or any of that.
I'm just going to let
Cloud Vision OCR it.
And my function will
get me the response,
look for the largest
dollar value on a receipt,
and then write that
information to Cloud Firestore.
And then Cloud
Firestore, maybe we
want to say aggregate over
the total sum of my expenses
that I can get that number.
So maybe that'll trigger
another Cloud Function.
That Cloud Function
will do a sum,
write back to Cloud
Firestore, and then notify me,
the user, in real time of hey,
you've uploaded this expense.
Your sum is now x.
And normally, you
could build this app
where your file storage
is public on the internet,
and your database is readable
or writable by anyone.
And those are obviously
very bad things.
So let's walk through
how to not do that,
so how to kind of do
that security as we're
building the application.
So my tips are structured.
We're going to talk about
a tip, and then we're
going to talk about the
mitigation along the way.
So as I mentioned, the
internet is a very scary place.
You should never trust
things on the client.
Because your clients can look
something like this, right?
If you've built a
web app on Firebase,
I'm sure you've copied
and pasted this config
snippet a million times.
It literally has an API
key, the location of all
of your resources, et cetera.
And if you leave your resources
public on the internet,
someone can do that.
And they can just say, oh,
I'm going to just write
to your database anywhere.
So you really can't trust the
client to do anything securely.
We've provided a number
of tools in Firebase
that help mitigate these risks.
But I get this all the time.
People are like, oh
my god, this is scary.
This is out in the world?
Yes, and it's by design.
And it's not a
problem if you follow
the rest of the tips
in this presentation.
So the first of those is, right,
I just said trust nothing.
But we have to trust
something, right?
Otherwise, we can't
really do anything.
And so the way that we do that
is via Firebase authentication.
And so we're going
to go into a little--
I guess, we're going to explain
how Firebase authentication
works, and why we
can trust it, and use
that as the root of trust for
the rest of our application.
So how many people have
signed in via Google?
I would assume almost
everyone in the room.
Great.
If anyone has looked at the
information you get back,
you get back information
like a user ID.
You get a profile picture URL.
You get obviously
your Google ID.
And you can imagine
a world where you
want to say talk to Firestore.
And you just pass
along those claims.
You're like, hey, I'm Mike.
And Firestore is going
to be like, wait,
anyone could say that
they're Mike, right?
That doesn't make sense.
And so identity providers
have taken to providing you
an access token.
So if you've ever done OAuth
programming or similar,
you get this access token.
And that's this kind
of opaque string
that just represents you.
And we actually can take
that in Firebase Auth.
We can kind of pass
that along and say, hey,
I've signed in via Google
with this access token.
And Firebase Auth
can say, hey, Google,
is this actually a
valid access token?
Has Mike proven that he
is who he claims to be?
And Google will be like, yep,
I can verify that that access
token is correct.
And Firebase Auth
will say, OK, great.
Mike has signed in
with Firebase Auth.
Let's actually give him a
user ID in Firebase, right?
Because we can
have people sign in
via Google, or Facebook, or
Twitter, or a custom provider.
We kind of need some
standard that we can all
rely on within the
Firebase products,
and so we'll give you a UID.
And that also allows you to
do things like a user signs
in anonymously, and then we can
upgrade them as they sign in
and merge those accounts.
We'll give them a user ID.
And we will also say, hey, take
this other cryptographically
signed token.
So if folks are familiar
with a JSON web token,
we give you this JSON
web token that says
information about that user.
So it looks like this.
It's this long kind of
seemingly opaque string.
But it has three
important parts.
It has a header, and
that basically says,
this is the algorithm
that was used
to sign the token, et cetera.
And then this is the juicy part.
It has a body with
a bunch of data.
And that data has
all the same kind
of provider specific
information.
So things like the
name, the email,
the name of the
application used, and then
some other custom claims, like
hey, I signed in via Firebase.
Here's my Google.
Or I signed in via Google.
And Firebase, here
are my various emails.
And then it has--
and this is the most
important part--
it has a signature.
So there is no prior knowledge
of cryptography necessary.
Don't worry.
But basically what
happens here is Google
has a public private key pair.
So one thing is secret,
your private key.
And then we offer a public
key for verification.
And Firebase Auth will kind
of translate that Google
credential into a
Firebase Auth token
that it signs with
its private key.
And so it basically signs
the header and the data
and puts that in a signature.
And so if someone comes
along, and they change--
they intercept your token.
And they try and change it, that
signature no longer matches.
When Firestore,
or Cloud Storage,
or any of those
Google properties
will try and understand that
token, they'll say, hey,
something's wrong.
The signature doesn't match.
And so that is kind of
where our root of trust
comes from, right?
And it would be,
obviously, very bad
if those private keys leaked.
And so we rotate them, and we
do all of those security things
so that you are not trying
to build your own identity
provider.
Don't roll your own crypto.
Don't build your own
identity providers.
There are lots of
people who've done this.
So we have done the mistakes
so that you don't have to.
And then we fix
them along the way.
So now when I want to go and
query Firestore, I can say,
hey, here's my JSON web token.
Pass that along.
And then Firestore knows how
to validate that and pull
a bunch of claims out of that.
So there you go.
It can say awesome.
You're Mike.
You're this user ID.
Here are all the
properties associated
with you, which gets us
to our next part, right?
So we know who our users are.
And we can verify and trust that
they are who they claim to be.
But there are a couple
of other steps, right?
We've done our
authentication of just yes,
you are who you claim to be.
But now there's the
authorization step of can
you do the thing that
you're asking to do?
And then, because again, we
don't provide you a server
to do all these things,
we have to say, OK, how
do you do schema validation?
So when you upload a file,
it looks like a certain way.
Or how do you do business
logic to validate that someone
isn't inputting malicious data?
And that's where
security rules comes in.
So Firebase security
rules kind of
stand between your
client and the backend
that you're accessing to provide
you those additional features.
And it does so via this thing
called Attribute Based Access
Control.
So some of you have probably
heard of Role Based Access
Control.
And we'll talk about
that a little later.
But Attribute Based
Access Control
is just, here are a
bunch of properties.
So the user ID, the
request that you're making,
the resource that
you're accessing,
go and derive some
decision based on that.
So we'll walk through that.
Hopefully, some of you
have seen this before,
but if you haven't
not a big deal.
We typically start by
defining a service.
We are writing rules on storage.
And then we offer this
kind of match construct.
And so we say--
if anyone, for instance,
has used the RESTful
APIs for Google Cloud Storage,
storage.googleapis.com
slash b slash the name
of the bucket slash o
slash the path to
the object, We're
just doing the same thing.
We're saying, OK, let's
match kind of a RESTful path,
or the resource that
you want to access.
That little squiggly
character is a wildcard.
So in this case, we're
going to say, hey, match
the bucket in your project.
And similarly, we
can say, OK, let's
imagine that we're naming the
images that we're uploading
to Cloud Storage for
Firebase, this user, the name
of your user ID,
expenses, and then
your expense.jpg or expense.png.
And then I can do
these allow constructs.
So I can say allow a
read or allow a write
if some condition is true.
And this is the
attribute based part
that I was talking
about earlier.
Because those
attributes could be
if the user matches the
user ID that were here
or a number of other things.
So we'll start
with the first one.
And we'll say only let a
user read their expenses
or write their expenses.
So this request.auth.uid,
we're basically
pulling a field out of
the token and matching it
to a name of the file.
And then we can make it a
little more complicated, right?
We can say, OK, any user can
read only their documents
or only their expenses.
But now we are going
to enforce a few more
constraints on writes.
Because we don't want someone
uploading a 5 gigabyte tar
ball.
We want someone
uploading a thing
that has to be an image
less than a megabyte.
And again, we can pull
in those attributes
and make decisions
based on that.
And then lastly, we can
enforce certain pieces
of business logic.
So imagine you don't
want to allow an expense
to be overwritten
because maybe someone is
trying to change it to look
differently after the fact.
They Photoshopped it to
have a different value.
And so we're going to say we're
going to require that they
can't overwrite their object.
So if there's already
an object there,
we don't let them write it.
So that's kind of a
very simple example,
but hopefully, it shows you
the power and flexibility
of these rules.
OK, so we've uploaded our file.
We've done so because
we authenticated.
We wrote some rules to ensure
that it's the correct thing.
Now we trigger our function.
And so our function could
look something like this.
If you've ever written Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
you pull in this
Firebase Admin library.
We also pulled in a Google
Cloud client library for Vision.
Right?
We're going to make one call
out to the Vision API to OCR.
We are going to write a little
bit of code that says, hey,
find the biggest
number on the screen.
And then we're going to write
that out to Cloud Firestore.
And the one thing that I
really wanted to emphasize here
is we're actually
running as an admin.
So this function is kind of
not running as an end user.
It has a higher
level of privilege.
And it's actually running
using a service account, right?
So we signed in our users
with Firebase authentication.
But all of our compute
is running as this kind
of robot service account user.
And that uses Google Cloud IAM.
And so, historically, inside
of all of your functions,
all of those functions
run with the editor role.
We kind of have one identity,
and they all get editor.
So that means that if you
screwed up your programming
and maybe there are
cases where someone
uploaded a source code file, and
your function [INAUDIBLE] it.
Potentially, that function could
now create virtual machines.
Or it can't change IM roles,
but it can build other resources
or do things that it really
shouldn't be doing, right?
All our function needs is this
concept of least privilege,
right?
It needs to read from cloud
storage to do a vision check
and then write to
Cloud Firestore.
So we have this concept of
per function identities.
And what that means is you can
create a new service account
and have that be given just
the amount of privilege
that it needs.
And you can do that
via custom roles
in IM or minting access
tokens if you're accessing,
say, the Google Drive
or Google Sheets APIs.
So we'll walk through that.
So I have a function.
It was called OCR receipt
because that's what it does.
It OCRs a receipt.
And I'm going to create a new
service account to represent
the identity of that function.
And then I'm going to
create a custom role,
and I'm going to call
that role only the Cloud
Vision in Firestore thing.
And I'm going to pass
it two permissions.
And this is a little
counterintuitive.
Vision actually needs object get
because we're pulling from GCS.
And then the only
permission that it
needs to right to Firestore is,
again, sort of confusingly data
store entities create,
as a bit of legacy there.
But we've now gone
from editor where
it could do anything in our
project, module a few things,
to exactly two permissions.
And then we are going to
actually grant that new role
to our identity, and then we're
going to redeploy our function
with that identity.
So now we've, again, gone from
this incredibly overprivileged
role down to exactly
the two permissions
that we need to read
from Vision and Storage
and then write to Firestore.
And then one of my
other favorite things--
so Vision, you may have
noticed, doesn't actually
have an IM role.
So it relies on OAuth scopes.
And so you need this scope,
for instance, the Cloud Vision
scope.
And so we'll give it
the Cloud Vision scope.
And it doesn't
fit on the screen,
but we'll give it the Cloud
Storage scope as well.
So it can go in right there.
And we can use this cool thing
called the metadata server.
So the metadata server
basically is an HTTP server
that kind of looks like it
lives on your compute instances.
And what it will do is it
will fetch tokens for you.
So when you deploy--
right?
How many people-- and be
totally frank with me--
how many people have
uploaded a service account
to their compute?
Or like occasionally,
you upload it to GitHub
because you screw up.
I've done it.
It's terrible, yeah.
I see a couple hands on that.
Yeah, that's not great
development practice, right?
Because maybe your private
repo becomes public,
or somehow, those
credentials leak.
The point of the
metadata service
is that you don't have to
ever deal with credentials.
You can just say, hey, metadata
service, give me a token.
And we refresh those
tokens every half hour
or an hour so you're not
touching credentials at all.
You can just say
this is my identity.
Give me a token
for the identity.
And so that's what
we're doing here.
And we're actually
even saying, give me
a token that scoped only to
the two or three services
that I need.
And I can make that
request, get the token,
and then do my calls.
And under the hood,
our client libraries
are doing this for you.
I just want it to
be very explicit.
Hey, this is a really cool
piece of functionality
that we provided
actually just recently.
OK.
So we've kind of
gone through half
of our flow, where we've been
able to securely upload a file
and then run some things as
admin securely before writing
back to Cloud Firestore.
So the storage
rules that we wrote,
I would categorize
as pretty simplistic.
If you've ever written
Cloud Firestore rules
they're a little trickier.
So we're going to go through
some similar concepts
and then see kind of how we
extend that into the future.
So as I mentioned--
and this is going
to be kind of a slight
point of difference--
that write that we did
from the function happened
as an administrator,
which means that actually,
a bunch of these rules
are not enforced, right?
Because we go through IM, and
we do an IM check that says,
hey, your function is running
kind of as an administrator.
Let's check there.
This is mostly the
Firebase rules are mostly
for your end users.
And they're kind of designed
purposefully for that.
But I'm going to go through
an exercise of we also
want to ensure that maybe
there is a category of user who
is writing their expenses
directly to the database.
Maybe we have a mode in our app
that you don't have a receipt,
and you just have to put
in the amount manually.
We still want to
provide for that.
So we would have to kind
of write that schema out
in our database.
And also, it's
just good practice
to see people walk through this.
So we'll start off with kind
of a similar set of constructs
that we had earlier, right?
You have a service.
In this case, it's Firestore.
And you have that kind
of similar boilerplate
path of databases,
documents, et cetera.
For those of you who
haven't used Firestore,
it's a document
collection database.
So you have collections--
for instance, expenses--
and then a document
named the expense ID.
So expense.jpg, or whatever.
And we're going to say we
actually care a lot more
about schema validation,
so imagine we kind of did
the authentication
check, and we did
a if the user can do whatever.
We want to validate,
for instance,
that unlike just the file
name, like we have in storage,
maybe our documents have
to have certain properties.
So in this case, we're
actually going to write three
properties, the image URL--
so we could pull down our file
and display it in the app--
the amount of money,
and then the user
ID of the user that
actually wrote it.
And so the first
thing that we did
was we basically said
this document can only
have those properties.
That's what that
has only check is.
And the next thing
that we're going to do
is we're actually going
to type check those.
We're going to
say, OK, the image
has to be a string because
it's just a URL out to storage.
The amount has to be a number.
And the UID also
has to be a string.
It's just a Firebase Auth UID.
So we've done just
simple schema validation,
but then we can do some
more complicated things.
We can say, for
instance, the image URL
has to match a certain
regular expression.
So only allow them to store
images that are stored
in Cloud Storage for Firebase.
Or maybe we don't allow receipt
expenses over $1,000, right?
We're like, whoa,
you shouldn't be
doing that in our mobile app.
So we're going to limit that.
And the last one
that we want to do
is kind of that quick
auth check of the user who
is writing this document has to
actually be that user, right?
I don't want to impersonate you.
I don't want you changing my
document later, et cetera.
And then if we wanted to,
kind of for completeness,
we could say things
like allow update, allow
delete, et cetera.
If a rule is not specified,
everything fails closed, right?
That's how this
whole thing works.
So don't worry.
Your entire database is
not public on the internet
unless you do something like,
say, allow reads and writes
everywhere, which
that is an option when
you start in test mode.
You can say yes,
allow everything
to be public on the
internet because it's
really fast to iterate.
Not great development practice,
and I'll get into some ways
that we can help kind of make
that easier in the future.
But there's another tool, right?
If you're looking at
that and you're going,
oh god, I have model
classes with 15 or 20
different properties and I'm
storing them in Firestore,
this is going to get crazy
to do that all manually.
Do we have the tool for you?
So I always feel kind of funny.
I work at Google.
I've worked at
Google for a while.
Has anyone heard of
protocol buffers?
A couple of you?
OK.
It's a Google conference.
I guess it kind of makes sense.
So protocol buffers
are basically
a way of defining a schema
independent of a programming
language.
So it's an interface
definition language.
So I can define
an expense proto.
And I can say, hey, that
has a string, image URL,
an amount of money, and a UID.
Those fields are all required.
Maybe actually I should
have made image URL optional
because maybe we have people
typing in expenses manually.
But you can actually generate
a bunch of things from that.
For instance, you can
generate all of your classes
for your model objects.
So for instance, it would
create expense.java,
and it would create
expense.swift, and TypeScript,
and whatever other languages.
And we've extended
it to also create
rules to validate those
model objects, right?
So what happens
here is your flow
is you define your objects
and protocol buffers.
And then it generates the
model objects and your client,
as well as the rules on your
server to validate those model
objects.
So if you're always deploying
those things in sync,
you should never
get to a point where
things are kind of egregiously
broken in your data model
because you should never
be writing those things.
So definitely check that out.
It's kind of an
open source tool.
You can run it
yourself, and it will
generate all of the various
model objects that you want,
as well as rules
to validate them.
And that makes it a
little easier, right?
Because now you just say,
oh, is this an expense?
And pass it in.
And it's like yes or
no, it's an expense.
You still have to include
whatever kind of other business
logic checks you have.
We're actually investigating
imagine if we go back
and instead of just saying
what they are, imagine
if you could specify
conditions in a proto as well,
to say, hey, this value has
to be between 0 and $1,000
in amount.
And then we could kind of
automatically do that as well.
So there are some kind
of interesting ways
for improvement.
The other one, just
kind of going on a limb,
is actually going in
the reverse and saying,
you have a Java class.
Generate me rules off a
Java class to validate it.
Well, that's a little
bit of a harder problem,
but still something
super interesting.
And if anyone is looking for
fun computer science problems,
definitely build something.
Share it with us.
We'd love to see it.
Cool.
So we talked through
that example of a user
writing some more complex data.
Now we know that our
users are going to be
reading from our information.
So we'll do a similar exercise.
We'll say, great, users can
read all their own expenses.
Everyone should know
what this looks like.
We're just going to say, yep,
you can get a single document,
or you can query for
all of your documents,
assuming that your ID matches
the ID in that document, right?
Remember when we
created things, we
had to ensure that
those were matched.
We're going to do the
same thing on queries.
And so this would
prevent me from querying
someone else's data, which
obviously we don't want.
And that's where we get
to the first gotcha.
And this is why Firestore is
a little interesting, right?
So you can imagine that
we have in our expenses
collection three
different expenses.
And maybe we have
more than that,
but we'll start with three.
And there are two
expenses by me,
user 12345, for $10 and $3.99.
And then some other
user has $1.50 expense.
So as you can see that and then
our other one is different.
And so you might kind
of natively expect that,
hey, I have this
set of rules that's
saying only give me my things.
I'm in a query, and maybe I'm
going to get only my documents.
And that is not how
things work, right?
People get really
tripped up here
because Firestore's like,
no, I can't feasibly give you
only those things, right?
Maybe there are
only three items,
but maybe there are
three million items.
And Firestore isn't going to
look at every single document
to be like ah, yes, Mike
needs these three items.
So you may kind of
reformulate that and be
like, oh, I'm in development.
All the documents
are my own, right?
I own every single one of them.
And that's the only
thing in the database.
So you may do the same thing.
You may say, hey, give
me all those documents.
They're all mine, right?
And nope, Firestore
still can't do that.
And again, kind of
what's happening
is we have to know kind
of beforehand if we
can fulfill the request.
Right?
So you actually
have to say, hey,
write a query that says give
me all of the documents where
the UID is equal to--
I hardcoded 12345.
But what I would do is I
would pull my UID client
side off that token
and then match that.
And in that case, Firestore is
basically asking this question,
right?
Can I prove that this operation
will be allowed without ever
looking at the data?
Right?
Because if we had to look
at a billion documents
in order to return
you one document,
that would be an incredibly,
incredibly slow database,
an incredibly slow product.
And that's not the
promise of Firebase
and especially not
Cloud Firestore,
where we have to do tens
or hundreds of milliseconds
of sync time.
And so the answer in
that case is yes, we can,
because you've provided
information in the query
that we match with the
rules that you've written.
So that's the concept
that you kind of need
to think about when you're
writing Firestore rules is
we are validating it based
on the rule and the query,
not based on the
underlying data.
OK.
So I said that I'd
come back to this.
What about role based
access control, right?
So we've been living
in a world with--
we'll go-- oh, I won't
go all the way back.
But we've been living
in a world with a bunch
of different attribute
checks, right?
Of ensure that the size is
less than this and the UID
matches this.
But I think a lot of
people conceptually
think about things in role based
access control terms, right?
You're like, I'm a user.
Maybe I have a
construction worker role.
Therefore I can
access a tool box.
Right?
Life just sort of
works this way.
So RABAC as opposed to
ABAC, user role resource.
And maybe there are cases.
We've gotten a little more
fancy in our application.
And we work for
a big enterprise.
And they have admins who
are checking our expenses.
And we have to give
the admins access
to view our expenses
to audit or whatever.
And so we can write this
little kind of local function
and say, hey, if it's
me, allow me to read it,
or if this person
accessing it is an admin.
But how do we get to that
kind of is admin check?
We can do that a couple ways.
But the simplest
is you can actually
write this kind of little
local function, is admin.
And what it's going
to do is it's actually
going to look up data
that is in the database.
So you can create access
control lists in your database.
Or for instance, if you're
building kind of like sharing
information, if you're building
a Google Docs or Google
Drive clone, you
could say, hey, these
are all the people who
have access to a document.
In our case, we're just going
to create another collections
called admins.
And hey, we're going
to look up and say,
is this user in the
admins collection?
And if they're in the
admins collection, great.
We'll allow them to be an
admin, which of course, brings
this amazing interesting
question of like, oh, well, how
does someone get in the admins
collection if doing so now
grants them these
magical powers?
The zeroth order
answer is the one
that I commonly do is literally
just go into the console,
and copy an ID, and paste it in.
But that's obviously
not super scalable.
So let's imagine that
we're going to actually use
another piece of
functionality of Firebase
Auth in our integrations, which
are called custom token claims.
So a custom claim
is something like we
have here of is admin flag.
And if we go all the way back to
that first section on Firebase
Auth, we talked
about that token.
And we talked about the body.
And within that body,
there are a bunch
of normal claims like my email.
And we can augment those
with custom claims.
So we could, for instance, when
that token is being created,
create it with this
additional flag that
says this person is an admin.
Therefore, they can do
another set of things.
So you might be like,
oh, man, that's awesome.
I can put all sorts
of information.
I can put the company
that they work at.
You can put group information.
You can store profile photos.
Don't do that actually.
I had someone do a 10
megabyte profile photo.
Turns out HTTP headers do not
take well to 10 megabyte photos
in the header.
And so we've kind of provided
a couple limits on that, right?
So custom claims aren't
kind of a panacea
for all of your
authentication needs, right?
We limit them to
a kilobyte so you
can only kind of put static
data and small amounts
of static data.
And also, we don't want them
to be heavily dynamic, right?
These things are refreshed
when the token gets
refreshed roughly once an hour.
And so don't store information
like the chat rooms
that a user is allowed to
access because they'll still
be able to access it
for an hour, right?
If you need small
dynamic pieces of data,
store that in something
like Firestore
in another collection, and
do a lookup like we had with
exists to actually look and
see if that document exists.
Two shameless plugs.
So Jen Person, one
of the Firebase DAs,
did a really good talk that
dives all the way into use
cases around custom claims, when
you should use them and when
you shouldn't.
And then if you enjoyed the kind
of data modeling perspective,
yours truly gave a absolutely
fantastic YouTube video--
yeah, not biased at all--
where we dive into kind
of more complex examples.
And then we also solve
that bootstrapping problem
of how does the first
user get into a place.
So we've written a
bunch of code thus far.
I don't know about you.
I know when I write my apps,
I don't always test them.
So I'm not going to ask people
if they test their apps.
But it's something that we
all know that we should do,
like brushing our
teeth and flossing.
And we're going
to try and make it
as easy as possible to
do those things, right?
So there are a couple
of ways that we
provide to actually test that
functionality out, right?
I wrote a bunch of rules,
and you're like, great, Mike.
Those look fine, but prove to
me that they're actually secure.
So that's what we're
going to do now.
So we provide the first
tool, which is a simulator.
And so a simulator
is in our console,
we allow you to write
where you edit those rules,
actually test that
those rules are doing
what you think they're doing.
So I've copied that
exact same set of rules.
Over on the left
side of the screen,
you can see, hey, we're
going to try a create.
And we can create a document.
So I actually went to the
taco trucks across the street,
and so I don't have
an expense for it.
But imagine that cost me $10,
and I took a photo of it.
So the photo is stored
over in storage, $10.
My UID-- remember
that number, 12345.
Great.
I'm going to build
that document.
I'm going to go down to
the authentication section,
and I'm going to put
my UID in there, 12345.
And then I'm going to click Run.
And Run is going to say,
yep, your read or your create
to expenses slash lunch has
all those keys, matches,
is less than $1,000, et cetera.
But if, for instance, I just
changed that Firebase UID
to 13579, so
basically not myself,
but I'm trying to write
a document that has that,
it's going to fail that write.
And that's obviously by design.
And the same would happen
if I say change the expense
to $2,000 or similar.
It would kind of give you that
nice failure message of hey,
something's wrong.
So it's a really nice
way of doing that.
If I drop the
simulator down, it'll
also provide a total
version history, right?
So every time I save and
redeploy those rules,
I'll have a version history.
So I can kind of
test that as I want.
And then if something broke,
I could, for instance,
kind of one click
rollback in the simulator.
Hey, get back to a safe state.
But obviously, that's kind of
nice for these one off things.
But ideally, when
you're developing,
you have a little bit--
you have unit tests or
an integration test.
So we also provide
a local emulator.
And so the local
emulator will basically
allow you to programmatically
do those similar tests.
So you'd have your rules.
And you have kind of
your local database.
You can read and write to it.
And I can create--
hey, in my expenses
collection, maybe I
want to go and fetch your
expense versus my expense.
And I've written rules
that kind of do that.
And then I can write
assertions and say, hey,
this test should fail under
this set of circumstances.
But maybe this test
should succeed.
And then I can validate those.
So that's a really
nice way of, again,
getting more towards the
automation of your security.
Awesome.
So we've talked a lot about the
deep technical aspects of how
to secure your application.
But there are a lot of
things that actually I
think are more common
and more frequently done
incorrectly that are much
bigger security vulnerabilities.
So I'm doing another
talk tomorrow--
shameless plug number
three, I guess--
that goes really in-depth
on kind of threat models
and threat environments.
But basically the
idea is there are
threats in the world, everything
from the random people
on the internet pinging your
website to state sponsored
entities who are doing very
targeted and specific attacks.
And so in the category
of threats, right,
when you build an
application, you
want to kind of pick
the threats that
are most likely because
those are obviously--
they're more likely to occur.
Therefore, you should kind of
try and solve them initially.
Unless-- again, it depends
on what you're doing.
But generally,
understanding kind
of what threats are
out there, what tools
may be used to break
your application,
or have malicious things.
One of the most common ones--
and I think we call
it sort of insider
risk or unintentionally
malicious behavior--
is everyone is really worried
about this guy, right?
The hacker who's sitting around
trying to break into your app.
But practically speaking,
it's like this guy from IT
who accidentally
deleted everything.
That's a much bigger threat
than this thing, right?
Much lower probability, maybe
a little more dangerous,
but practically
speaking, if this
is going to happen
98% of the time
because they clicked
the wrong button,
that is still a
really big threat
that you want to deal with.
So this
mike@mcdonald.com guy, we
don't know if we can trust him.
I wanted to add
him to my project.
And typically, my alter
ego is an editor, right?
Or is an owner.
I can do anything
in this project.
But maybe I don't really
trust this other one.
And so I want to give him kind
of more specific permissions.
I don't want to give
him full access to, say,
all of my business
data or access
to send push notifications.
I want to say, hey,
Mike, I'm going
to give you a particular role.
And we can actually
go and say, OK, there
are some analytics roles
that are reader or writer.
There's maybe a develop role.
And Mike is going to be doing
some development work for me,
so I'll give him the
developer admin role.
So he can go and delete
the entire database,
but he can't send
push notifications
to spam all of my users, right?
So there is some
guide rails there.
And if you need, you can
kind of bump out of that
into Google Cloud Platform and
use the custom roles in Google
Cloud Platform to create similar
to what we did for our IM
example, give mike@mcdonald.com
only access to a database
and maybe even only read
access to a database
and write access to storage.
You can kind of create
whatever you want
and give them that custom
role, and the Firebase console
will respect that.
And the last one, again, kind
of going a little more abstract,
but developer experience is a
really, really important part
of security, right?
Because if your processes
are really cumbersome, right,
if you have a bunch
of manual steps,
people are going to kind of
bypass them or take shortcuts
and end up in places where you
kind of unintentionally built
vulnerabilities into
your application.
And there are a
couple of common ones
that we see really,
really often.
Shared environments
is a huge one, right?
So for those of you who are
running Firebase apps today,
you may have things like
your dev, and your beta,
and your prod apps all
in the same project.
And that means they're
sharing an auth database.
That means they're sharing
an actual database.
That means your metrics are
kind of looking interesting.
Projects are kind of a nice
firewall between those, right?
Because you want an
entirely separate database
that if someone comes along
and accidentally deletes it,
that's fine, right?
It was staging.
You can rebuild it.
And so really, really
recommend that.
And I think there are a lot of
people who say, oh man, it's
really hard to set
up environments
because it requires a lot
of manual toil of enabling
all of your APIs, et cetera.
So tools like Terraform
or Deployment Manager
will help you kind of
build that infrastructure.
So the infrastructure
as a code type thing
will help you do that easier.
And really into that, right,
if you have a very manual tool
chain, a lot of times, people
will do things like they have,
for building an iOS app,
have the one Mac Mini
in the corner of the office,
where they build the app on.
And then put a thumbdrive in,
and take the IPA file off,
and walk it over
to another computer
to upload it to iTunes Connect.
That's a really bad
experience, and you're
likely to copy the wrong file
or do something like that.
And so, CD tools, so
using Cloud Build-- or we
have a really great
mobile tool called
Fast Lane, which does things
like automate provisioning
profile signing, and
upload to the app store,
and kind of doing that securely
so not everyone at your company
can say upload an
APK to the app store.
Only the Cloud build
deployment agent can do that.
You can kind of build some
additional security in there.
OK.
So that is all I have.
I have about 10 minutes.
If you have questions, I
am happy to answer them.
And I will stick
around after as well.
Otherwise, please
submit your feedback.
And if you have other questions,
I'm on Twitter, @asciimike,
A-S-C-I-I-M-I-K-E, and would
love to help you wherever you
are in your development journey.
Also, if you've built
awesome Firebase apps,
send them my way.
Send them to
Firebase on Twitter.
Write into support.
Again, I love seeing
what you build,
and I may try and break it.
And give you feedback on that.
So thank you all
very much for coming,
and enjoy the rest of Next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]